[Music]
oh
[Applause]
take it easy sweetheart
you looking for me
see you met the twins
boy hear everything they say
i guess we both are
how you doing
i'm ass
bruce wayne
sorry i wouldn't be bothering you here
but your people keep telling me you're
unavailable
you know you really could be doing more
for this city
your family has a history of
philanthropy but as far as i can tell
you're not doing anything
the riddler
is asking for you the killer left this
for the batman why is he writing to you
are you okay
i've been trying to reach you
there's latest it's all about the wings
if we don't stand up no one will
you got a lot of cats i have a thing
about strikes
the bat and the cat
it's got a nice ring new friend of yours
i'm not so sure
i'm just here to unmask the truth about
this cesspool we call a city
you're part of this too
how am i part of this
oh you're really not as smart as i
thought you were
bruised
away
all these years
in life to
we all have our scars bruce you're still
away
he's involved in this oh he's not
involved how do you know she's afraid
where are you under there
what are you hiding
don't worry honey i got nine of them
it can be cruel poetic or blind
but when it's denied
it's your violence you may find
justice
the answer's justice
come on vengeance
let's get into some trouble
[Music]
you